ah
e
y
[Música]
ah
y yo sea un ajuste a una ley
bueno mi firma
tengo para mí con sus primos
el juego and day
o
ah
[Música]
bersin
your father del entierro
[Música]
vuelvo a diciembre vídeo
ellos panamá minsa
cuando el juego de
dios
[Música]
por qué
hay otro día
cáritas
[Música]
yo soy pues con de estar sólo a muerte
bueno mi firme vida
[Música]
bien
luego a mí
con la guitarra
[Música]
[Aplausos]
y
[Música]
ahora
ah
[Música]
muy fuerte
ayer me dirás
eres tú
[Música]
qué sé hablar con the stars el amor y
bendiciones audio ironía malo bueno
límite mía
power
pero no
[Música]
denigrar entre bandas
ahora dios
querían emprender
[Música]
hoy
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah
una vez
[Aplausos]
[Música]
ah
bien
[Música]
[Aplausos]
e
[Música]
gracias
da por invitarnos a estar en su evento
antes de continuar nuestra breve
participación
en este bloque es ser
más en
y algo más adecuado que el blues que
creció en un entorno adverso con
instrumentos que no eran propios de su
cultura
tomando influencias de diferentes
culturas cuando llegaron a américa los
afroamericanos
y antes no era ofensivo decirles negros
y siempre hemos sido buscando con el
vocabulario ser cada vez más delicados y
ser muy sinceros sin ofender entonces
ellos hicieron esta cultura y hay
cientos de festivales en todo el mundo
eso es crecer en tu entorno
y eso es la música que ellos nos han
dejado y nosotros estamos tocando aquí
en méxico viniendo a nuestro nuestra
experiencia personal con estos
excelentes amigos y músicos le apostamos
a tocar algo que no es comercial entre
comillas y somos orgullosamente el grupo
que tocamos más veces a la semana
trabajamos cinco días de la semana
diario tengo mensajes de cuando se te
ofrezca si no puede ir cooking sobre el
yo voy saben que trabajamos que tenemos
un nicho de mercado lo importante
entonces creer en lo que tú haces aunque
sea diferente
tras puro de la luz equipo
vamos a hacer algo de las raíces del
blues vamos a cambiar un poquito el
setlist ser con estilo dios te lo solía
tocar reid trans
[Música]
un
pero
[Música]
soy
lauryn hill
y está la gente de allí era joven
vivir
font y barceló
[Música]
yo a él
miren se va
[Música]
color abono
o no
v
vivir
más bien
bueno
son y por qué no
pero no
[Música]
lo usual
olano
ayer
soltaron el vino
[Música]
bien
la calle
[Música]
y the next winner
bueno
[Música]
v
y vivimos
la primera
bien
font y volteo
efe
[Música]
ah
e
[Música]
y
la verdad
a
[Música]
pero
vivo
[Música]
pero no
guzmán
[Música]
olano
am su taller
es otro hombre
su médico
la carne
viven extra
ella
como veis
vivir
más
porsche
bien
[Música]
como divorcio
no lo vi
ahora sí
[Música]
no
o no
gracias
o ser la raíz del blues robert johnson
escribió esto originalmente es muy lento
en guitarra acústica luego ser un
poquito diferente
[Música]
la conocen del mundo
ah
primero
cómo
a
[Música]
an
nos hemos puesto
sweet o chicago
[Música]
como yo
no
[Música]
ahora
weiss
sweet o chicago por que carmona
considerado mejor guitarrista de blues
en el país por la misma revista cuatro
años consecutivos
[Música]
ah
a
[Música]
para mí
y
[Música]
yo estoy viva y amor
peritoneo
[Música]
o sí
en excelente día
[Música]
la gestora proyecto orgullosamente que
de monterrey
señor booking carmona
varias nominaciones al grammy como
productor
carros ruth ya tres años como mejor
bajista checo como por baterista en la
misma revista
el grupo cinco años consecutivos como
mejor grupo gracias por habernos
invitado
crezcan en su entorno crean en ustedes
[Aplausos]